feel free to call me karen peter for
saying this what the hell are they doing
having a rookie dinner and a pandemic i
i
like this this is the raiders issue all
over again like
where where's this disconnect coming
from that there's this nonchalance like
yeah we're going to go out and have a
rookie dinner and i know they're tested
every day i know
so are the ti so are the titans and
they're not playing this weekend i i
just i
am i wrong to feel that way
is that wrong was that wrong i guess i
would just i would say this that
i don't know what the what the details
of the rookie dinner are
are they going to be in some banquet
rooms somewhere uh
you know in the same space and and all
that maybe it's going to be an outside
event somewhere who knows maybe they're
going to be mask wearing until they
actually eat the food i don't know
i wouldn't get too upset about it but
i'd want to know where the meal is if i
was mike tomlin i'd want to know where
the meal is and i'd want to know what
the rules are going to be
yeah i agree with you completely and i
just after what happened with the
raiders on monday night i'm not going to
rule out anything and my antenna are
constantly up now because here's the
thing tuesday morning the ultimate the
ultimate jinx peter tuesday morning
one thing i said to sims on this program
well the good news is we've gotten
through 48 games and covet 19 isn't an
issue
congratulations nfl and then what
happens titan stealers get postponed
right after the show ends this raiders
video comes out and it just shows you
number one how easy it is for an
outbreak to happen even with all these
protocols and number two how stupid
people still are
about
jeopardizing their ability to earn their
football game checks i've said this over
and over again all week you know derek
carr is going to lose 1.1 million a week
if raiders games aren't played and he's
out there at this event
in a confined space with no mask and and
there's this like it just
anyway i i'm i'm looking and watching
now for the next thing that there's the
video that's potentially going to create
an outbreak because that's where we are
with everything good the nfl has done
and it has been overwhelmingly good the
fact that there is a postponement this
weekend of the steelers titans game
presumably to be rescheduled week seven
with raven steelers going to week eight
and the ravens taking their by week
seven and the steelers and titans having
an unexpected buy this week there's a
way to fix it but it's still very
alarming because with everything they're
doing it still happened to the titans
and if it keeps happening every few
weeks what's gonna happen peter we're
gonna get to a point where we're not
gonna be able to make a game up we're
gonna have teams that played 15 games
you're gonna have an eight and seven
team and a nine and seven team or a nine
and wait a nine and six team let me get
it right a nine and six team get into
the playoffs over a nine and seven team
because the nine and six team didn't
have to play a 16 game that might have
lost
i mean mike
those are the things i just sort of
shake my head at those and i'll tell you
and the reason i shake my head adam is i
wrote this column back in may
that
you better get used to this being a
really unfair season
someone is going to get screwed and
screwed bad i don't know who it is i
don't know what it'll be but you just
said exactly
one of the ways that it could happen and
when that happens
you know if a coach screams with outrage
i'm just gonna say listen do you have
any idea how fortunate you are to have
gotten almost the entire season in
in a year like this when now it appears
that the pandemic is coming back with a
vengeance you see what's happening in
wisconsin right now you know
last night on nbc nightly news
they had a correspondent in green bay
and the green bay hospital
okay is chock full of coven patients
okay the monday night game is there this
week and i'm not saying they shouldn't
have the game i i i don't mean that what
i mean is that this is happening in an
nfl city okay and we got to get over
this thing that says oh my god if if
somebody only plays 15 games it's it's
some tremendous injustice
i i'm gonna just say mike who cares
i don't care yeah i mean
we have to we have to get used to the
fact that the players and the coaches
have it in their control
you have it in your control and i'm not
killing anybody in tennessee i have no
idea how it happened could have been
ridiculously accidental i don't know
but however it and i'm not they
shouldn't get any discipline they should
no i'm just simply saying
these things will happen it was a lot
flukier
in the first two weeks of the season
that
2460 players
for a total of 15 testing days
nothing showed up
then
for one player in week three to be out
you know in atlanta and now for a game
to be postponed in week four
i'm just gonna make this point mike
if that pattern continues
and once every four weeks there's one
game postponed
and and it happens four times this year
the nfl would have had a hell of a
regular season
yeah i agree with you completely and i
have uh text messages from a coach who
was livid when the nfl was doing what
was potentially perceived as victory
laps in august about all the success
with the testing because the concern is
you're going to make people complacent
they're going to let their guard down
they're going to do stupid things like
what we saw on monday night from the
raiders but you know i think back to the
commissioner before the season when he
refused to acknowledge that there's a
competitive disadvantage for some teams
having fans and some not having fans he
should have just said then you ain't
seen nothing yet because
whether or not fans are present is a is
is
minuscule in comparison to some of the
inequities that may have to arise in
order to get the games in and peter i
wrote this last night and and you
mentioned it with the titans you know
mike rabel said it earlier this week
there's no one to blame well i i you can
argue there is someone to blame whether
it's they haven't designed the protocols
well enough to keep out the virus or
people didn't execute the protocols well
enough to keep out the virus but the
fact that the virus got in shows there's
you know a defect somewhere and so at
what point do you just take all the
teams and create a hard bubble in each
city and just tell them for the rest of
the year you're living at the hotel and
if i'm the nfl i'm having those
conversations right now with the nflpa
so we have the opportunity to move
quickly if we get to a point where it's
like yeah well you know what we need to
do this we we we need to implement the
mini bubble protocol and send every
player every coach every critical member
of every team to a hotel and they're
staying there for the rest of the year
and that's the only way we're getting
all the games in
i think it's an interesting concept and
if this is if if this continues to
happen
uh i think it's very worth the
discussion i think it's worth a
a sort of a preemptive discussion right
now but i i i would also just make this
point mike that
that
you know there are a lot of people i
talked to one front office guy
for a team this week who told me that he
told his wife he's got two children he
said listen i'm gonna be around but i'm
gonna be in the guest room
because i can't be the one who he's got
two kids they're school age kids
and he says i i can't be the one
who might
bring it to my team i don't know what my
kids are bringing home from school i
just can't trust it and so he is already
in sort of
a self
uh
you know a self-made bubble in his house
and again that's not the same thing i
understand this
but i do think that teams ought to be
given the chance right now
to get this right on their own and if
they can't
i think it's definitely worth a
discussion as you say
and here's the thing
the margin for error is small here we're
fortunate that the titans and the
steelers are going to be able to
configure schedules and get this game in
once teams start having their buys and
the buys are gone then you get to your
concept of week 18 week 19 at some point
you just run out of
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports